no ciao a tutti lavorati stories vita
benché me ogni tanto sospirata forse ma
si sente meglio di fare queste valenze
quest'azione si chiama cento strati di
slime nome a benevento
in pratica come funziona
noi estremo girare la ruota capitano e
gli ingredienti che scattano andremo a
metterli nel opposte chiello la gioia ci
finisce una cosa che se chiedo il pieno
una volta che pieno lo stimiamo ti diamo
lo sly non rischiamo lo teniamo fuori e
vediamo che cita più bello
quindi faremo uno slalom gigante
tantissimi strati è una cosa definisce
una volta caffettiere piero senza
secchiello e primate mi iscrivo in più
un'altra regola siccome ovviamente non
ci stavano tutti i nomi delle cose di te
che colorante verde giallo blu ma ci
sono poche cose quindi non è solamente
colorante per scegliere il colore o il
tipo di palline bisognerà ferirle hobbit
i coloranti e dovremo per carne 18 c'è
scritto finanza che quello che capiterà
stever ovviamente quindi siete pronti
invece tv come di patatine forno e fate
il tifo per me
alla fine del video come sempre dovrete
portare delinque istituzioni tale in
botte la bellezza dello slam ei suoni fr
e ora iniziamo subito abbiamo glitter a
quanti glitter abbiamo per esso non li
puoi scegliere chiudi gli occhi
aspettano ma è ok a inserto i glitter
dorati gialli prego tutti si primo
strato assistiamo ora tocca a me non
indica ancora d'oro e più verso
colorante bello il primo strato di
colorante il mancato però che a chiedere
agli occhi ai non verte non scappiamo in
fondo non quadrano quello quale caviamo
[Musica]
va beh certo la tangari avverte blu roma
le pendenze che riesca dopo primo strato
di è stranissimo scegli tu cosa sei ma
può succedere alla gola è certo anche
quello che vi conviene di più bianco
trasparente e l'ecologia sempre porto
gatto padrò mettere quanto vuoi tu come
tutta siano giganti insomma secondo
strato più che mi capita una cosa
[Risate]
palline abbiamo varie palline qua quindi
chiedo agli occhi ha detto lieto ma
insomma
caratteristiche queste non verde o meno
male o trovare tutto si ribalteranno
vedremo combatte per il secondo strato
di slime toccate sento io
vediamo a maggio ma che cosa voi
scegliere come indecisa tra colorante
per beckham lo sapevo
oppure non dire che non sono certo il de
canio dice e quindi quindi potrebbe
essere che ti capita a terra ha un
capitale di ambiente possa essere una
sfigata colorante verde per te quello
che va bene di fiore agricolo ben vedere
tutti mischiati tocca a me
[Musica]
palline bianche ei più ma che fortuna
per un attimo la barba tante feste la
bellona dispetto bianca anche per me era
più bello e tutto mio e per l'effetto
botti e stranissimo sembrata una piscina
di palline bellissima al centro c'è la
piscina di corda
[Risate]
di nuovo nuovamente glitter che fortuna
aspetta che gli gnocchi vai che però è
ripreso due
[Musica]
quello che noi ha offerto i glitter a
forma di cuore perché della più bella è
ormai sotto quella glitter chi non è
capitato anche a me dove la strada è
aperta sia da sofferti questo perché
burrai e perfetto grida più veloce più
letto chiudi gli occhi ma nuovamente ed
esami e sono le stelline gialle detto
come vediamo
devi girare più veloce quanto
tipicamente presente siamo tirati su
questa partita sono tipo delle palline
[Risate]
la neve sta come aiuterà un sacco o vizi
non lo so potrebbe anche rovinare tutto
lo slime allora devi aggiungere la neve
che devi aggiungere un po di acqua per
attivarla attento a cantar eletti ok la
stella strade synth conta metterne
dentro gente ma adesso poche gocce
nettamente gonfia di fare di più
poi vedremo come diventa ok tocca mese
contento ero più colorato e pieno giochi
da sceglierla ben che vada meglio almeno
perché se mettiamo un qualche cosa che
conta quasi tutti foto con durante la
via degli occhi dove anche il blu
procura di roma caserta
quindi forse un po di testo
l'azione dimora che ti farà tanti suoi
fmr le campane ovviamente a questi ora
registriamo piccole campane
[Musica]
punizione ma come capita in questi
termini grezzi rosa
cosa non ci crede chi guarda del mio
punto è bene contro tutti no
[Musica]
grazie al bellissimo guerra fredda porta
perché schifezza
guardate che schifezza perché bellezza
che lo scambiamo lamentela sento certo
però lo yo yo yo ma
[Risate]
[Musica]
[Applauso]
prego tiri da tre colorante quasi
l'accattonaggio parlerà save the mirror
fantastico lancioni delizioso ci sto
benissimo e penso che stiamo più a o mio
dio guardare il es
ecco la guardo
[Applauso]
[Musica]
felice diventerà un bridge schifoso
questo silvio biondo ma anzi credo
questo e sit com che sarebbe caduto più
mai segni to casciello ma bensì come
sono un po ti faccio a sfidare la colla
quale è un disco a recuperarlo questo
slime orrendo oddio a vincolo estranei i
bravissimi cambio maledizione
[Musica]
l'opzione pascolo 2 ore al centro da mr
x mary commento quindi tutto riguarda
con la bianca nuovamente nettamente
[Risate]
[Musica]
altra neve con possibile dal fatto che
si chiama un paio di cose belle
chiamo l'acqua
addio sta diventando tipo una palude
io cambio di colore tutto questo molto
triste questo spazio è prassi tanto che
hanno beh ho contribuito io a farlo così
belle e con tutta la colla verso messo
tocca a me temo solo sperare che in
questi ultimi turni non mi capiti il
cammino come che se non sarebbe
veramente il colmo
quindi facciamo due ultimi round
[Musica]
no di mystic sfida possa fare bello
stile
siete scettici successo niente
l'hai capito niente niente servizio
scambio cambio fumetto franchi e
maledetto ogni cosa certa per alimenti
peggiori a te ok ragazzi come di solito
quarti sembra un po lì in pattino torta
ma forse non diventa verde sembra una
palude
c'è troppo stranissimo forse lo diventa
verde diventa la grigio ancora meglio
forse è stato iniettato celeste forse
mischiavano bene riusciamo a recuperarlo
sta diventando bird e vediamo un po come
diventa il mio che adesso io volevo
parte che è un sacco di bambini e quindi
farò ancora un sacco di fumo sono solo
bravo sono anche fortuna ma è andato il
bravo bravo e fortunato fortunato perché
tele rubate
allora diamo attivando lo slime è
successo qualcosa di brutto
cioè si è staccata poeta che ora è
sommersa nello zaino
non ho idea di come recuperarlo perché
ancora non è attivo quindi ora aspetta
una corretta che resistiamo più ridotti
farlo c'e voluto un sacco di tempo
perché enorme pesa un sacco
allora siete pronti a vedere gli struzzi
canti quindi possono vedere una volta e
poi dovrete dare per aspetto e per sony
smr da con il mio ok sud est e chiare di
slime allora
lo faccio vedere meglio sono contenta
che il colore alla fine non è uscito
verde ma è una specie di animale come
diceva spesso di verdeaqua celestino
infatti siamo usciti simili però
lattanzi spetta è molto diversa non è
super elastico per abete grande e
gigantesco c'è enorme sentiamo un po di
suoni super talking che 7 vitale che si
era spaventata ma a mio agio cortese non
hai voluto
vediamo un po qua c'è superano capire
allora e praticano consistenza vedete si
vedono i pezzetti di neve infatti sembra
una sorta di snowblind un bel flop è più
quello che non è molto lucido morbido
wow che può king pazze
si no
[Musica]
purtroppo non ha nessuno pallina a
questo è bella e grande lobby gigantesco
[Applauso]
vitale zito che osserva come fare
d'occhio si vedono alcune stelline kate
e vi devo dire che sono a questa
contenta di come un sito pensato molto
peggio perché aveva fatto l'unione
all'avana e terribile intermente però
una volta mischiato devo dire mi piace
il colore che piacevano con se stesso
supersport 3 2 1
io poi ancora volesse qualcosa non ha
funzionato o che queste armi outline nei
commenti da temi non è questo slime ora
passiamo allo slancio vitale che lei mi
ha detto che hanno tutti perso il tool
armi che mi ha lasciato le aree
collegate
siamo pronti credo allora il colore
innanzi tutto ebbe inizio non solo dopo
tante poi le palline in maniera migliore
per data la densità del colore
escludendo cioè solo tiriamo giorni per
me andare facciamo un bellissimo ma lei
è stimato benessere ea profit in gol
allora come consistenza lega è
fantastico spiega cosa cercano le paline
i glitter super elastico morbidissimo
questi glitter di rosa sono meravigliosi
anche questi blu è il colore
ringraziamo anita per il colore questo
trattamento non desidero che su pochi
allora aspetta un attimo faccio vedere
troppo che ti dove dico io mi farebbe
contenuti non lo stand del summit
smoking che nel frattempo bisogna essere
citato rivedere la decima perché nessuno
andriano dovete vedere la sua faccia su
frattempo ecco il parla a sto giro
comparare le coste convinto troppo forte
ebbene folle cipolle quella bolla
si sentono ma che bello con il colore
sotto bene lungo a tutti questi bei
suoni fantastici la consistenza
meraviglioso perché belle queste queste
palline all'interno blu e bianche che
chiamano benissimo questo valore
stupendo poi che ci manca altro
rianimazione
che bello è andata una sciarpa aspetta
il mio intervento e faticosi dall'antico
ne frego questo è il piano del becco
giallo lo slime allora
aspettate un posto donna10 per aspetto e
persone e lo tempo vitale dategli anche
un nome
questa volta non sapete come dati potete
dargli rumori quanti si sa bene se vi è
piaciuto questo video anche un bel like
e diteci di affitto diteci che arriva da
ballo hashtag rischia libero sotto 21
giochiamo contro castellini qui potete
cliccare per vedere i prossimi video
cliccate su quella che preferite e ciao
ciao